for some exercising hate might even  reach a professional level and could  create a level of dependency on this  catastrophic feeling however nietzsche  identifies that this exercise is a  conscious one and that most of the time  it is pursued rather than randomly  acquired with regards to love nietzsche  puts emphasis on the idea that love  needs to be learned indeed love although  it is considered the preeminent feeling  it also constitutes one of our most  arduous quests  love isn't something that transpires  organically love is something that needs  to be cultivated if this fails to occur  one will lack the capacity to show love  and most possibly one will be oblivious  to the love offered by those who  actually know how to exercise it